[Inaudible] [inaudible].
I saw that both lists. Hello?
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, a lot of their pocket.
[Inaudible] daily, daily, the period. So
[inaudible] [inaudible] um, they will be famous. That's done, man.
They can help me better.
Do, uh, do I, do I buy for the tall
[inaudible] tail? Uh, 31st of March. Uh
[inaudible].
I said your,
the, the [inaudible] [inaudible] they go into
[inaudible] or yoga? [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
I use
[inaudible] you ask me? I mean, it I'll be at the
[inaudible].
Um, [inaudible] uh, October, uh
[inaudible] um, or, or hot
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible].
Menthol pointed out if the menthol, so what are
[inaudible] also
[inaudible] what we is this [inaudible], um,
[inaudible] of him. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] how to do
[inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] they do all the things that they
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] stuff at my mum. My [inaudible].
I love there.
Uh
[inaudible] um,
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] instead of who
[inaudible] put our newborns
[inaudible] around a very long theater. Evandale
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
So the first day or the first
[inaudible] the Optum from telephone or the 90 into workers on this
Facebook
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] can generate
[inaudible].
Uh [inaudible] uh
That'd be part though. The portable medicine. Oh,
Marshall [inaudible] serotonin
[inaudible] [inaudible] the first day or so, whatever internal pillow
[inaudible] um, man, uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] son. So would it be with better?
[inaudible] I think the old man [inaudible].
No
[inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh, normally see I'll do better on the [inaudible].
Thank you.
[inaudible] [inaudible] so my bought the house, so we had a week
[inaudible] is still your
[inaudible] [inaudible] save a pillow somehow. Small
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] neither had that game over. No.
Absolutely. Um,
[inaudible] there are, you know,
[inaudible] and
[inaudible] man. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] so, so bladder out, do other, uh,
spell out the so-called casino, um,
foot at the Velda expert in whole middle wound bed and the whole middle
[inaudible], uh, vault, Vidal, Dell,
all that. The Cheetos builder.
Yo
[inaudible] [inaudible] man, man. Don't see star
[inaudible] day. You don't have, [inaudible] not constantly. I mean,
for humbling and the film, the
[inaudible] I can't focus here. I'll focus. [inaudible] eh
[inaudible].
Or who died in a, spent that the
[inaudible] new [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
And men's do heart. Uh, so, so hard. Uh
[inaudible] um,
[inaudible] um, at the Shaun, the rest of the opposition's budget.
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, we,
Lucas nivo will so blessed with that while living at my
vault. [inaudible] eh, uh,
mess that the awake.
The way I love
[inaudible] [inaudible] we are called not
[inaudible] only. Thank you. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] you'll be okay.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] I mean,
[inaudible] SMS.
[inaudible] give them hell. They will mean give him hell yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Give.
Him head office. The
[inaudible] news. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
No.
[inaudible] well, it starts, [inaudible] taken into means to
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] so gall. Uh, so I didn't look. Health net
[inaudible] it failed. [inaudible]
Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible].
We call it Mart.
[inaudible] What are your man? I don't wanna
[inaudible].
Overdo tailor-made it fell and
[inaudible] [inaudible] nickname.
The thing
[inaudible] do most of them also
[inaudible] mom at home family, but most of the
[inaudible] it
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] I think
No, but I'm going to [inaudible] some Rocky
[inaudible] or the
[inaudible] the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
So with Dominic, he would start the [inaudible] SMS and give him, hell dad,
listen, when you get him.
[Inaudible].
Uh, no Stanford.
[inaudible] [inaudible] um, [inaudible].
Uh.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
You me.
[Inaudible] ideally.
[inaudible] how you can just party
[inaudible].
And I.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] versus with mum, mum [inaudible]
cheap with some
[inaudible] that, that women do [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
NEDA
[inaudible] [inaudible].
No, hold on. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh, and then
[inaudible] you will not
[inaudible] in the whole
[inaudible] to see your new work culture.
Yeah. It's [inaudible].
Lesson for them.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Oh, video, Vietnam.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
Yeah. And she likes and people to Hartford architects for the art Institute.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] eat fruit for the sale of the habit you take for in particular.
[Inaudible] so some, some of the hotel example.
[Inaudible] plus [inaudible] it happened here.
[Inaudible] you have a story.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] or your
[inaudible] stole money.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Lee
[inaudible].
Uh, Los
[inaudible] hunting company, field marshal, some that, uh, uh,
[inaudible] uh [inaudible] uh, the contact department handle.
September [inaudible].
Oh, well thank you. [inaudible].
Um, you know, I always said the
[inaudible] was over there.
[Inaudible].
Oh, so you're in the community.
[inaudible].
You.
Also
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] don't skip [inaudible].
[Inaudible] okay.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Nah, nah, I've done the house and we also wouldn't have field. Remember
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] Give him hell.
Yo also, uh
[inaudible].
Before you can do [inaudible].
No, before we go.
[Inaudible].
Email song. There's dot protocol.
Isn't that it doesn't have a point there that you focused very much on the
inequality and the inequality as a problem, but it isn't,
isn't the most important thing to too.